Today you are going to see a lot of papers
come alive in the world around us. Why? Well,
NVIDIA just announced their shiny new H200
graphics card. And this is a big deal. In fact,
to say that it is a big deal in my opinion
would be an understatement. But first,
bad news. It is pricey, few if any of us are going
to be able to buy this. So, I hear the question,
Károly, why do we have to speak about a graphics
card that we won’t buy? Well, I have good news
too. We don’t have to buy it, and yet, each of
us can still enjoy their advantages. I’ll tell
you how in a moment, and first, let’s roll up the
sleeves and have a look at what they can do. So,
what are the advantages of such hardware?
Well, it can simulate a landing on Mars,
power supercomputers, or run
a fusion reactor simulation.
And it can perform these beautiful
fluid simulations, tornado simulations,
and visualize solar flares. Protein folding, this
leads to a better understanding of the building
blocks of life, and it is already being used
for creating new kinds of medicine. Something
that was so difficult, we always thought was
only going to happen in the future, and now,
it is here. Of course, these graphics
cards also power video games. And what is
this here? Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two
Minute Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Okay, kidding. This is an aerodynamics and
acoustics simulation around this new car.
New hardware can typically do more
intensive tasks than previous generations,
or it can do the same tasks and consume
less energy, like it is doing here,
something that we have to think
about more and more in the future.
You see, the jump from GPT-2 to GPT-4 requires
orders of magnitude better hardware. Consider
this: GPT-2 had 1.5 billion parameters. GPT-3
175 billion parameters. A jump of more than 100x.
Then, GPT-4, more than 1.5 trillion parameters.
A 1000x difference. This requires tons and tons
of compute. And today, specialized versions of
it already exist, get this, where scientists
created a chemistry assistant that can not
only answer your burning questions about
metal organic frameworks, but it also learned
to predict crystallization outcomes as well.
And today, NVIDIA can train a GPT-3 AI
not in years, and not even in days, but,
hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars, and look!
Less than 4 minutes? What? Oh my goodness. Also,
stable diffusion in less than 2.5
minutes. Incredible AI systems are
now being trained in a matter of minutes.
My mind just refuses to comprehend this.
And it just got even better. This is
with the “old” H100 graphics cards,
and they now announced H200. This has almost
double the memory capacity. Wow. This is one
of the main limiting factors in how big
of an AI system we can get access to,
and it just got nearly doubled. Memory bandwidth
is now up 40%, and almost broke a mouth-watering
5 terabytes per second. We are almost there. And
of course, things are also going to run faster
too. Way faster. Loving it. So good. And B100 is
coming next year, so make sure to subscribe and
hit the bell icon if you would like to hear
me flip out over it. Of course, if it is any
good. From the extrapolations, wow, buckle up
Fellow Scholars, it is going to be real good.
So this hardware improves all things AI, and
today, AI is a piece of software that writes
new kinds of software. See where this is going?
This is the engine of scientific development. And
we just got a new engine. And compute power
just keeps increasing at an incredibly rapid
pace. And today, no field of research, no branch
of science remains untouched by these techniques.
So, why is this good news for all of us?
Well, even if we don’t buy this hardware,
this powers the tools we use day by day.
ChatGPT, and many other AI tools that are
absolutely everywhere. I am also happy to see
Lambda, our long standing partner showcased
here. Great job! And remember, 92% of Fortune
500 companies use ChatGPT, and we haven’t even
talked about any other AI here. And two,
it is also fueling the next iteration of
research works. It is fueling the papers, so
we Fellow Scholars are very happy to see this.
And one more thing about increasing hardware
capabilities that put this image into perspective.
In AI research, there is, or perhaps at this
point, I can say there only was two schools
of thought. One, Richard Sutton argues in his
landmark article by the name, “The Bitter Lesson”,
that AI research should not try to mimic the way
the human brain works - he argues that instead,
all we need to do is formulate our problems in a
general manner, so that our learning algorithms
may find something that is potentially much better
suited for a problem than what our brain is doing.
He argues that the best performing learning
techniques are the ones that can leverage
computation, or, in other words, methods
that improve significantly as we add more
compute power. Two, the other school of
thought: people tried to encode lots of
human knowledge of strategies in their Go AI,
but did not have enough compute power to make a
truly great algorithm. And now we have AlphaGo,
which surprisingly contains minimal information
about Go itself, and yet, it is better
than the best human players in the world.
So what does all that mean? Well, in other
words, algorithms are extremely important,
I don’t need to argue for that on
this channel, but, never forget:
compute is just as important. And this new
graphics card is a metric ton of more compute,
turns out, for all of us. Even if we don’t
buy it ourselves. What a time to be alive!